[موسيقى
] يشبه أرفف متجرك اليومية
المليئة بالوجبات الخفيفة
نظارات السباحة الواقية من الشمس
ولكن هنا كل الأيدي الموجودة على سطح السفينة هي حرفياً
الحالة تسمى aquapod وهي توفر
كل ما تحتاجه لقضاء يوم صيفي
على الماء في دبي ،
لذا فإن الفكرة الكبيرة وراء الأكروبود  هو
سد الفجوة بين الحياة البرية
التي تعيش على البر الرئيسي
والمعيشة في الخارج وأن يكون لديك مجتمع
مكتفي ذاتيًا أو
مستدامًا في البحر
لمدة أربع سنوات قام أحمد أوسف
ببناء القرون العائمة التي يمكن أن توفر
جميع أنواع الخدمات هذه  يمكن للسوبر ماركت
أن يخدم العملاء الذين يطفو على السطح
ويقفز على متنه أو يمكنه تقديم
التطبيق من خلال تطبيق مصمم خصيصًا للعملاء
في البحر ، كما
أن التطبيق نفسه مخصص أيضًا
للبيئة
البحرية ، وبالتالي فإن نوع العنوان الذي
يأخذه العميل هو نفسه.
كلا الاسمين كلاهما رقم وهذه
هي الطريقة التي يمكننا بها العثور على dnc سهل
وتنفيذ الطلبات
أحمد هو رائد أعمال متسلسل
أطلقه أيضًا ab
يتوسع مفصل urger وصالة توسع صالة aquapod
مما يمنحها 25
مساحة إضافية إلى داخلها وكما
ترون الآن فإن الأرائك
تخرج فعليًا من الأكوابود
عندما تطفو في الخارج ، يجب أن
تعمل القرون خارج الشبكة وهذا يعني على
الألواح الشمسية الموجودة على السطح أسفل صهاريج تحلية المياه
تنتج المياه العذبة
وتجمع الحاوية في الخارج
النفايات العائمة من البحر
كما أنها تحمي
البيئة وهذا ما يجعل Aquapon
تطورًا مختلفًا تمامًا
عن القارب العادي أو المركب البحري
وفقًا للشركة
يقدم سوبر ماركت أكوابودس ما يصل إلى 50
قاربًا مختلفًا في أيام الذروة
لمحلات البقالة ، تعد القرون المستدامة لأحمد
نقطة جذب كبيرة ولديه
خطط أكبر
من المنازل العائمة إلى المراكز الرياضية
والمجتمعات المتنقلة بأكملها
قد يكون لديه سبب مع
ربع مليار في العالم معرضة للخطر
يمكن أن تساعد الهياكل البحرية ذات الاكتفاء الذاتي من ارتفاع مستويات سطح البحر في
الحصول على مصادر الطاقة الخاصة بك
الوصول المباشر إلى مصادر المياه الوفيرة
من البحر ، هذه كلها
جوانب مهمة جدًا للمدن
التي تتطلع دائمًا إلى امتلاك القدرة
على إيجاد بدائل
وحلول مختلفة للتكيف مع بيئة الاقتصاد المتغيرة باستمرار
والتطورات
في هذه الأثناء  أحمد لا يزال طافيًا
وهو الآن يصطاد لعملاء جدد في
المياه العذبة
.